voici les premiers visiteurs du mob en
ce mercredi beaucoup d'enfants
accompagnés de leurs parents tous
impatients de commencer la visite
c'était l'occasion lé musée rouvre
aujourd'hui et le mob en particulier
donc on en a profité le temps était un
peu gris aussi donc avec les enfants ont
placé qu'une voix la girafe derrière la
la fenêtre alors là mon fils il m'a dit
on va voir la girafe mais est ce qu'on
pourra rentrer chez nous on va rentrer
on a réservé on va rentrer une
impatience combler dès l'entrée dans les
salles d'exposition
le bâtiment a été entièrement repensé
six ans de travaux ont été nécessaires
on a reconstitué un nouveau musée
entièrement à la fois visible de
l'extérieur avec cette nouvelle serre
mais aussi là où on se trouve
actuellement avec ce grand atrium on a
percé les trois étages pour les relier
entre eux les données beaucoup des
respirations quelques squelettes
beaucoup d'animaux naturalisés
le muséum a enrichi sa collection avec
cette météorite par exemple des
changements apprécié des visiteurs
d'un point de vue purement esthétique
découvrir ces espaces noir sombre c'est
très agréable
effectivement ça permet de mettre en
valeur les pièces qu'elle quelle soit
les animaux les informations les les
interactions qui sont proposées aussi il
ya aussi plein de choses lui dis qu'on a
eu des petites choses là-bas a aimanté
avec accompagnement pour les tout-petits
mieux après les trouve aussi un
visuellement c'est très intéressant dé
superviser adore tous les d'animaux
le muséum ne peut accueillir plus de 185
personnes en même temps
soit un quart de sa capacité il est donc
conseillé de réserver qu'aux vide oblige
le musée s'adapte et modifie son offre
toutes les animations interactives ont
été mises de côté on a pris le parti de
ne pas mettre de la rubalise et
d'interdire tous ces dispositifs mais
plutôt de les cacher quand on pouvait
parler rendent accessible avec des films
des réussites par exemple on a pris le
parti de les cacher de diaba vous
découvrirez en fait plus tard une
surprise plutôt que d'interdire quelque
chose alors qu'on dit dans mon père avec
beaucoup d'interdits déjà aujourd'hui
l'inauguration officielle du muséum est
prévue en septembre